is esteemed colleagues good day
hello
we are meeting on the eve of the day of
the reunification of crimea with russia
we all remember that in those difficult
weeks of march 2014 people from crimea
and sevastopol manifested expressed
courage and patriotism and stopped the
neo-nazis and radicals those who
organized and conducted
in kiev and people in crimea and
sevastopol didn't budge they united and
prevailed
they made their free and conscious
decision to be together with russia the
years after that proved how correct
and timely
that choice was
it suffices to look at what's happening
today in dunbas and everything becomes
clear
i suggest discussing a work on
strengthening the social and economic
potential of
crimean sevastopol
and where we should focus our efforts
on which tasks
in now and in future starting from 2015
we have been
implementing a special program uh to
develop the crimea
uh into
and and it's a society and economic
the program the special program
is funded and
1.7 billion rubles is allocated for this
program
and this money
should
be
funding more than a thousand facilities
and more than a half of them already
ready
uh
and they're already
working for for the locals a lot of
attention was paid to developing of the
structure infrastructure a modern
uh airport was built in siem veropol
so the br the
crimean bridge
was launched and a new motorway tavrida
was launched
energy supply to the region became more
stable
thanks to new
energy generating
capacities
and
new facilities replaced the outdated
facilities this solved such a problem as
a
long-term
blocker blackouts